[Music]
526 on your Finally Friday what's
driving you crazy well maybe not a deal
breaker but shutting down a freeway ramp
in the spaghetti bowl for an entire
weekend well that ought to get your
attention
it's the ramp that takes you from the
Northbound 95 515 to go north on I-15
Nevada Department of transportation's
Justin Hopkins says crews are going to
be doing kind of the same thing they're
doing on Desert Inn over I-15 not
exactly repaving it's known in ndot
world as bridge deck overlay
pretty easy work around you want to get
off the Northbound 95 515 at Eastern
then go North to Washington and then
West to the north 15. so that closure is
scheduled to start at nine tonight and
run until five Monday morning buckle up
drive carefully and please put down that
phone you can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com